Well, it's 2025.
Happy cold New Year.
Uh, it's glad to be together in this warm place today.
There's always an air of anticipation around
the turn of the calendar.
I, I hope that your eyes are fixed on the Lord
for his purposes and plans for you this year
and how you can follow him in it.
I'm excited today, especially though
because we're diving back into our He Shall Reign series
through the book of one Samuel.
We started this back in August.
It's actually gonna take us all the way up until Easter,
a total of 29 sermons through the book of one Samuel.
So excited about that. If you're not already there,
take your copy of God's word.
Turn with me back to First Samuel in the Old Testament,
first Samuel 17.
You'll flip through the front of it.
You'll find Joshua, then judges, then Ruth,
and then first Samuel, chapter 17.
Put a bookmark there. We'll be in that
for the next couple months.
Uh, before we get into chapter 17 today though,
that's quickly review.
It's been a couple weeks since we were
here, uh, in this book.
So let's review where we've come so far.
If you remember, God's people had been freed from slavery in
Egypt and they had been wandering
the wilderness for 40 years.
They finally entered into the Promised Land.
Moses led them in and God had promised that to Abraham.
He finally gave it to them
and they were to be distinct in that land, both culturally
and religiously as a way to reveal God to the world.
He was their chosen people to reveal himself.
He'd chosen them uniquely and he wanted to be their God
and their king in every way in their lives.
Yet as they entered the land, things continue to go bad.
To worse, as people rebelled against God,
they failed to love God.
They failed to love each other In many ways, it led
to chaos in the land and into that environment.
After the Book of Judges was born, a boy named Samuel
whose barren mother, Hannah, was blessed with this child
and gave him back to the Lord and,
and he grew up to be a prophet
of renewal in the nation of Israel.
And during the time that he was growing up
and as he was leading, God proved himself over
and over again that he would deliver his people.
He had not abandoned them.
He would defeat their enemies on his own in miraculous ways.
He showed himself to his people that he's got them.
Yet still the people became enamored
with the nations around them.
And instead of following Yahweh as their king,
they rejected God as their king.
And they instead asked
for a king like everybody else around them.
Now God acquiesced, he gave them what they asked for
and he appointed a tall, impressive man named Saul
to be Israel's first king.
Now, if you remember, the King's primary responsibility was
to lead his people, to follow God,
to lead them into battle.
Yes, but to lead them to follow God's
covenant responsibilities.
And even though it wasn't ideal that God allowed them
to have a king, that wasn't his plan to begin with.
That's what he allowed.
But, but God would still make it work if
that king would follow him.
Well, we saw Saul quickly reveal
that his heart was not toward the Lord.
So he was a mighty warrior.
Yes, but God ultimately rejected Saul
because Saul had rejected the Lord's authority.
'cause God wanted a man
after his own heart, a man
who pursued his heart above all else.
Which is why we left off in chapter 16 where that point was
we saw God reject Saul and and looked past the exterior
and anoint a young man named David whose heart was
after God's.
And so you've seen this chart
before as we've walked through this journey,
what we're gonna see today is that continuing shift
from Saul to David.
You see their paths cross.
They're uh, aligned in some ways,
but it's really a comparative journey.
It's gonna take us through the rest of one Samuel,
between Saul and David.
They will just be contrasted the entire book.
And to kick us off in one Samuel again is one
of the most familiar scenes in the Bible known
as David and Goliath.
Now this is one of the most well-known stories even
by people who aren't Christians.
It's one of the most basic stories that people know.
The foundation know the skeleton of it.
You hear it on sports center every time the number one team
takes on the underdog, right?
It's David and Goliath. That's, it's just well known.
The basics of it at least are, But
what does the Bible emphasize in this narrative?
Okay, we know some of the story,
but what does the Bible, why is it in here?
Why is this story in here?
Did God include this just merely to give us content
for a locker room speech Or to
give you some courage against
that addiction that you're faced?
Or to say, man, this year's gonna be the year
that I finally follow through on that new year resolution
that I abandoned every January 8th, every uh,
you know like is this gonna be the year
David and Goliath, my story?
Like is that why this is here?
Well let's walk through it and we'll see one Samuel 17.
Now the narrator recorded this in a way that builds tension.
So we're not gonna read the whole thing.
We're gonna read it in pieces and talk about it in pieces
because you'll see why it's recorded the way
it is a piece at a time.
So first here it is the setting.
Uh, the first couple of verses show us the setting
of the whole thing verses one through three.
Now the Philistines gathered their armies for battle
and they were gathered at Soko, which belongs to Judah
and encamped between Soko and E Zika in Eim
and Saul and the men of Israel were gathered
and encamped in the valley of Elah
and drew up in a line of battle against the Philistines.
And the Philistines stood on the mountain on the one side
and Israel stood on the mountain on the other side
with a valley between them.
Now you're gonna see a map up on the screen here.
It's maybe hard to see what's going on fully,
but basically what you need to know is
that the Philistines were making an incursion
into the land of Israel.
They were trying to take over.
And so it ended up in this valley
where the armies were camped on the
either side of the valley.
So if you don't know what that looks like, think
of two stands at a football field
where one team's on one side,
their fans are all on this side and it's on the other side
and there's a field between them.
So that's kinda the picture. Philistines
and Israelites on either side with a valley between,
they can both see each other
and they can see the battlefield.
That's where we're at with the setting.
Which leads us to the challenge. This is the challenge.
That setting is in your head. You've got the picture.
Now watch the challenge get laid down by the Philistines.
They were trying to overtake Israel.
They opposed God, they opposed his people.
Watch the challenge that's laid out here,
verses four through 11.
And there came out from the camp of the Philistines,
a champion named Goliath of goth
whose height was six cubits in a span.
Now we have no idea what that is, right?
It's roughly, let's say about nine feet, nine
to nine and a half feet tall.
He had a helmet of bronze on his head.
He was armed with a coat of male
and the weight of the coat was 5,000 shekels of bronze.
Again unfamiliar. It's about 125 pounds.
And he had bronze armor on his legs
and a javelin of bronze slung between his shoulders.
The shaft of his spear was like a weaver's beam,
meaning a thick piece of wood.
And his spear's head weighed 600 shekels of iron.
That's about 15 pounds.
So his spear, just the head of it, weighed about 15 pounds
And his shield bearer went before him.
He stood and shouted to the ranks of Israel,
why have you come out to draw up for battle?
Am I not a Philistine? And are you not servants of Saul?
Choose a man for yourselves. Let him come down to me.
If he's able to fight with me
and kill me, then we will be your servants.
But if I prevail against him
and kill him, then you shall be our servants and serve us.
The Philistines said, I defy the ranks of Israel this day.
Give me a man that we may fight together.
When Saul and all Israel heard these words
of the Philistine, they were dismayed and greatly afraid.
Now let's just give them some credit.
Do you see why they were dismayed here?
It's why it's David and Goliath the giant. He's this mass.
Look at the picture of strength
and power it gives us of this mountain of a man
who has the latest
military technology all over his body
in front of him, on him.
He is the picture of worldly strength.
But don't miss something critical here.
See Saul and and notice Goliath mentions him a couple times,
Saul as the king of Israel.
He was the one charged with
leading his people into battle.
Which means if the other side sent out a champion on a A
representative, it was his job to take that challenge
to accept the challenge on behalf of Israel.
Yet what did verse 11 say?
It specifically said, Saul
and all Israel we're greatly afraid.
That's why in verse 12, we are immediately introduced,
reintroduced really to the person
that throughout one Samuel plays the contrasting role
to Saul, the one
who was anointed back in chapter 16 as the king.
We've already known his name. His name is David.
Now David is the youth referred to throughout this passage
and really other passages.
Remember David the shepherd's son of Jesse
from the little town of Bethlehem.
That was who David was.
Here's where he enters into the story. Watch this.
This is verses 12 down through 30 and it all fits together.
Watch carefully as I read this
Now verse 12 starts with now that's meaning to contrast
what just happened with what's here.
Now David was the son of Anite
of Bethlehem in Judah named Jesse
who had eight sons in the days of Saul.
The man was already old
and advanced in years talking about his father.
The three oldest sons
of Jesse had followed Saul to the battle.
The names of his three sons who went
to the battle were Elia of the firstborn.
Next to him had be Aada and the third Shema.
David was the youngest. The three eldest followed Saul.
But David went back and forth from Saul
to feed his father's sheep at Bethlehem.
And for 40 days going back to the scene for 40 days,
the Philistine came forward, took his stand morning
and evening, and Jesse said to David, his son,
take for your brothers an iffa of this parched grain,
a container, a bushel, and these 10 loaves
and carry them quickly to the camp to your brothers.
Also take these 10 cheeses to the commander of the thousand.
See if your brothers are, well bring some token from them.
Now Saul and they
and all the men of Israel were in the valley
of Elah fighting with the Philistines.
David Rose early in the morning, left the sheep
with a keeper, took the provisions
and went as Jesse had commanded him.
And he came to the encampment as the host was going out
to the battle line, shouting the war cry.
And Israel and the Philistines drew up for battle.
Army against army.
David left the things in charge of the keeper
of the baggage, ran to the ranks and went
and greeted his brothers.
And as he talked with them, behold the champion,
the Philistine of Gath Goliath by name,
came up outta the ranks of the Philistines,
spoke the same words as before.
And David heard him, all the men of Israel.
Verse 24, all the men
of Israel when they saw the man fled from him
and were much afraid.
And the men of Israel said,
have you seen this man who's come up like this is kind
of the rumor going through the camp.
Have you seen this man who's come up?
Surely he has come up to defy Israel
and the king will enrich the man who kills him
with great riches and will give him his daughter
and make his father's house free in Israel.
And David said to the men who stood by him,
'cause David just showed up, David hadn't heard much.
What shall be done for the man who kills this Philistine,
takes away their approach from Israel.
Who is this uncircumcised Philistine
that he should defy the armies of the living God.
And the people answered him the same way.
So shall it be done to the man who kills him.
Now Eli, the oldest brother, hell heard when he spoke
to the men, heard David say what he said.
And Eli's anger was kindled against David.
And he said, why have you come down?
With whom have you left those few sheep in the wilderness?
I know your presumption
and the evil of your heart
for you've come down to see the battle.
And David said, what have I done? Was it not? But a word?
He turned away from him toward another,
spoke in the same way and the people answered him again
as before her.
So you saw what was happening.
David finally ends up at the battle.
David hears what's going on
and apparently King Saul, instead
of accepting the challenge from Goliath,
he had instead tried to bribe a bunch of other people
to say, Hey, somebody's gotta take this guy on.
Why don't you do it? Here's, I'm gonna give you all kinds
of rewards if you would do it right.
Instead of saying, I'm gonna do this myself.
And what was the response? It was crickets, right?
Nobody said, I'll, I'll do it. Right? Nobody did.
They were all running and hiding.
Yet this time, morning and evening, he kept showing up
and challenging the people.
This time though something for the first time
we see a different response.
David's there. He hears what Philistine this Goliath said.
And what did he say in verse 26? Look again.
Who is this uncircumcised Philistine
that he should defy the armies of the living God.
See that for the first time
a theological interpretation is introduced to this battle.
Saul was supposed to have that they were all
as Israel supposed to have that kind of perspective.
But only when David shows up for the first time.
And as much as his older brothers were looking down on him,
'cause he was young, he just wanted to see the battle.
He is just a little kid.
David was the only one with enough sense
to rightly understand what was happening here.
Well, obviously word would begin to spread that this youth,
he had an edge that no one else seemed to have.
Well, that news finally made it to Saul, to King Saul
actually the one supposed to have courageous faith,
which by the way, that's why we put it in quotes here,
because in no way at any point in this narrative does
Saul act like a proper king of Israel.
It's just he doesn't show anything but a position.
He, he was in the position,
but he had no power of king of Israel.
And we'll see it here. Look at verses 31 through 37.
It says, when the words that David spoke were heard,
they repeated them before Saul and he sent for him.
And David said to Saul,
let no man's heart fail because of him.
Your servant will go and fight, meaning I'll do it.
Go and fight the Philistine.
And Saul said to David, you're not able
to go against this Philistine to fight with him.
You're but a youth. He's been a man of war from his youth.
But David said to Saul, your servant used
to keep sheep for his father.
And when there came a lion or a bear
and took a lamb from the flock, I went after him
and struck him and delivered it out of his mouth.
And if he arose against me, I caught him by his beard
and struck him and killed him.
Your servant has struck down both lions and bears
and this uncircumcised Philistine shall be like one of them
for he has defied the armies of the living God.
And David said, the Lord who delivered me from the paw
of the lion and from the paw
of the bear will deliver me from the hand
of this Philistine.
And Saul said to David, go and the Lord be with you.
Now again, I've told you the contrast is the whole book
of first Samuel between Saul and David here again, more
and more we see the contrast.
Saul heard David's speech
and he's trying to quench David's faith.
Now you can't do that. And David instead responds with
how he killed lions and bears.
He's like, I'm not scared of this thing.
But notice again, it wasn't just David had this courage
that none of us could have.
David's heart was towards the Lord. Watch his perspective.
That's so God focused.
He says, the Lord delivered me from those killer animals
and the same Lord will deliver me from Goliath.
Two. It wasn't that David felt so confident in himself.
It was like, look, the Lord did this there,
why wouldn't the Lord do this here?
There's even further contrast.
Look next verses 38 through 40,
then Saul, as he says, okay David, you're up.
Then Saul clothed David with his armor.
He put a helmet of bronze on his head
and clothed him with a coat of mail.
And David strapped his sword over his armor and he tried in.
David tried in vain to go
for he had not tested them.
Then David said to sa, I cannot go with these.
I've not tested them. And so David took them off
and he took his staff in his hand, a long stick
and he chose five smooth stones from the brook.
And he put them in his shepherd's pouch.
His sling was in his hand and he approached the Philistine.
Now it seems like in your head you're thinking this little
boy putting on armor it, it probably wasn't
that David was probably a a grown man
in some form at this point.
So it wasn't like he was too, it was too big.
It just, he'd never used it before.
He didn't know how to use the military armor.
But, but I want you to see this.
Notice where Saul's mind went
whenever David was about to go to the battle.
Saul's mind first went to the same military technology
that he saw on Goliath or that he trusted in himself.
He went to that that everybody else
trusts in when they to a battle.
Do you remember though how David had defeated the lion in
the bear earlier in his life?
Was it with swords and armor
and all of the military technology?
No. Now
as a shepherd he probably would've had a a staff
along stick and a club.
That's most likely what he had. Yes.
But remember who he attributed victory to?
He said it was the Lord
who delivered him from those animals.
David had trusted God to do
that here.
He trusted God to give the victory over Goliath.
He didn't trust a sword or armor or anything like that.
He trusted God would do it again just like he did it in the
wilderness with those animals.
He would do it again. And so see again the contrast.
Instead of leading his people
to trust Yahweh in battle in life as he should,
king Saul was just as afraid as anyone else,
trusting the ways of the world
and the things of the world like anybody else.
But David went in the strength of the Lord alone.
Saul was supposed to. David did it.
And so as young David assumed the role of champion
for Israel and he moves onto the battlefield in this moment.
Think back to the description of Goliath, right?
The giant, this mountain of a man armed to the teeth
defended in every way possible that you can as a human.
He is this huge figure imposing.
And here comes David a stick in his hand,
a sling in his hand,
and five, probably tennis ball sized rocks in his pouch.
But I want us to be careful here
because we can get distracted really quickly by
comparative size, military technology,
whatever we think like we, we can just focus on that.
There's a confrontation here.
And as we watch this confrontation play out,
we need to focus on the means employed to gain the victory
not on anything that some painting might draw our mind to
with David and Goliath in this confrontation
Goliath and everyone else
we're trusting in one thing while David
was trusting something completely different.
Look at this verses 41 through 43
and the Philistine moved forward
and came near to David
with his shield bearer in front of him.
And when the Philistine looked
and saw David, he disdained him for he was but a youth ruddy
and handsome in appearance.
And the Philistine said to David, am I a dog
that you would come to me with sticks?
And the Philistine cursed David by his gods.
Now I wanna stop there for a second.
'cause you see, Goliath brought a theological
understanding to the battle as well.
Back in this time there was this understanding that
military battles were competition between gods.
And so Goliath, knowing he had a home field advantage,
he was superior in every way he knew his gods
had no problem with this little youth.
See, this wasn't just about swords
and military technology here.
This was a way for God to show off.
This was a competition in a way between Gods.
And so the fact that Goliath also brought a theological
interpretation here shows us that
that's the root of this whole thing.
And so while it may have appeared on the outside
that David brought a knife to a gunfight here,
watch David's true weapon show up here in verses
44 through 47.
This is probably almost my favorite
passage in the whole scripture.
Watch this. The Philistine said to David, come to me.
I will give your flesh to the birds of the air
and to the beasts of the field.
Then David said to the Philistine, you come to me
with a sword, with a spear and with a javelin.
But I come to you in the name of the Lord of hosts, the God
of the armies of Israel, whom you have defied this day,
the Lord will deliver you into my hand
and I will strike you down and cut off your head.
And I will give the dead bodies of the host
to the Philistines this day, to the birds of the air,
to the wild beast of the earth that all the earth may know
that there is a God in Israel
and that all this assembly may know that the Lord saves not
with sword and spear for the battle is the Lord's.
And he will give you into our hand like,
I don't know about you, but that makes me wanna one
through a wall or something like that's just,
just gets going right there, man.
Like that is so good. Good. But did you see it?
What was David's ultimate goal?
It wasn't just to defeat Goliath, to defeat the Philistines
as necessary as that was, they defied God.
Yes. His purpose was that all the earth
may know that there is a God in Israel.
That's what he wanted. Like that's just the same thing
that God had told Abraham back in Genesis 12.
He said, all the families
of the earth shall be blessed through you.
It's in fact what Psalm 96 records says,
we are to declare his glory among the nations.
His marvelous works among all the peoples.
For great is the Lord and greatly to be praised.
He is to be feared above all gods, for all the gods
of the peoples are worthless idols.
But the Lord made the heavens
see the comparison again, right?
See, in God's economy there's always an evangelistic
Drive That God is not just content.
To have a few people
in a little country in the Middle East know who he is
and know him well.
His heart purpose from the very beginning
that David's heart was for, it's something
that we need to understand.
He heart is that his glory is declared
to the ends of the earth.
He's worthy of it.
He is the God above all other gods, but also
because anything else people live for is going
to be unsatisfying.
It's worthless any other God people
choose to walk forward to, whether it's a figurine
or whether it's an idol of materialism
or whatever else we live for whatever else we put
as supreme in our lives, relationships, kids,
whatever it is, we put that in front, it's always going
to be less than.
It'll never satisfy.
Nothing less than a relationship with Yahweh will satisfy
Us.
That's why his glory needs to be declared
'cause there's nothing else to live for that's going
to actually fill what we're looking for
and he's worthy of it.
That was David's heart. That's why God rejected Saul.
That's why he chose David. It's
'cause David's heart was right towards the glory
of God shining to the ends of the earth.
David wasn't being arrogant or prideful in any of this.
He was just humbly confident in his supreme God that
that nothing can prevent God's glory from shining
brightly to the world.
David just said, I wanna be a part of that.
There's nothing else to live for. I wanna be a part of that.
Which finally gets us to the actual battle like we've been
for 47 verses just leading up to
the actual battle itself.
And it really only takes two verses
because again, the narrator was focused not
on military strategy.
He was focused on theological interpretation of this,
the difference between the God who cannot save
and the God who does save.
Look at verses 48
and 49 when the Philistine arose and came
and drew near to meet David.
David ran quickly toward the battle line
to meet the Philistine
and David put his hand in his bag, took out a stone
and slung it and struck the Philistine on his forehead.
The stone sank into his forehead
and he fell on his face to the ground.
This is the victory that God gave to David.
This is the victory, only one of the five stones.
We don't know why he picked five,
but one stone is all it took
slung perfectly into the only vulnerable spot on Goliath's
armor right between his eyes.
Here's the thing though, most likely I didn't kill him.
Definitely stunned him
because look at this, this mortal Kombat like Finish him
scene in verses 50 through 54.
Watch this. So David prevailed over the Philistine
with a sling and a stone
and struck the Philistine and killed him.
There was no sword in the hand of David,
but look at what 51 says.
Then David ran and stood over the Philistine
and took his sword and drew it out of its sheath
and killed him and cut off his head with it.
When the Philistines saw that their champion was dead,
they fled and the men of Israel and Judah rose with a shout
and pursued the Philistines as far as Ga
and the gates of Ekron.
So the wounded Philistines fell on the way from Sha Reem
as far as Gath and Akron, that's all that area
to the west that we saw on the map.
And the people of Israel came back from
chasing the Philistines.
They plundered their camp
and David took the head of the Philistine
and brought it to Jerusalem.
But he put his armor in his tent.
This was the victory that God gave to David, which is
what David said was gonna happen.
Remember in his speech to the Philistine, to the Goliath,
he said, I'm gonna cut your head off.
What'd he do? He won the
battle this day.
The Lord brought victory. Now there's
actually one more scene here in chapter 17,
and I believe this is to be a setup
for the rest of the book.
Actually Look at verses 55 through 58 quickly with me
and we'll come back to the story.
But this is the contrast again between Saul and David.
Watch this. As soon
as Saul saw David go out against the Philistine, he said
to Abner, the commander of his army,
Abner, whose son is this youth?
And Abner said, well, as your soul is, I don't know.
And the king said, inquire who the son, the boy is.
And as soon as David returned from striking down the
Philistine, Abner took him, brought him
before Saul with the head of the Philistine in his hand.
And Saul said to him, whose son are you? Young man?
And David answered, I'm the son of your servant,
Jesse, the Bethlehemite.
Now if you remember a couple weeks ago I said
that I believe I I, I wouldn't die on this hill
but I I think the narrator flipped 17
and 16 chronologically that David
and Goliath was actually the first thing
that happened chronologically in the story.
But then 16 happened afterwards. But why did he do that?
'cause Saul doesn't seem to even know
who the guy is like this Dave, but
but in 16 it says he's serving Saul.
So how does this work out?
It seems like the narrator flipped it
because what he wanted to separate was God's election
of David in chapter 16 from his military
skills in chapter 17.
In other words, God did not pick David
because he was a champion warrior.
He picked David because David was a man
after God's own heart and he wanted God's purpose
in the world over everything else.
And that's all gonna come up again
and again as we go through the rest of the book, keep
that in your mind as we go into it.
Now, that's one
of the most fun narratives in all of scripture, right?
Like David Goliath, we love that story,
but here's the typical question then we ask as a result
of it, okay, what do we do with it?
But what do we do with that?
And and I've heard varying
interpretations of what we do with this.
I've heard teachers and songwriters speak about facing the
giants in your life with courage
because this little boy was able to defeat giant
with a sling and a stone.
And you can do that too, right?
Where we're like Dave with the giant pickle.
Remember that like little people can do
big things too, right?
That was the whole point of that.
But then I've also heard other teachers swing wildly the
other way and scream at people saying you are not David,
and go after them as if they're wrong
and say This is only about Jesus and sin and that's it.
Right? Okay, well in some way they're both wrong I think,
but also kind of both, right?
So what do we do with this?
Because It's true
that since Jesus interpreted the Old Testament
as talking ultimately about him,
the primary truth we do need to remember in this is
that Jesus did defeat the biggest giant we face.
Like we need to remember
that Jesus defeated the biggest giant for us
because Jesus is referred to as the son of David.
So often we look at David as a type
of Christ who's pointing us forward to the things
that Jesus would do perfectly, which means that all
of one Samuel 17 in that story, you are not David.
I am not David in that story.
You and I are Saul
and the rest of Israel hiding in the bushes
because we're terrified of that giant called sin
and we can't defeat it.
And so we needed a champion to come in
and rescue us
to win a representative battle for us so
that we could be free.
He would overcome that sin through his life, death
and resurrection, that we could never defeat
that enemy ourselves.
That's ultimately what this is about.
Yes, that you
and I as sinners, hiding, scared,
defeated you
and I can receive the victory of Jesus
as we believe in faith that he's won the battle for us.
Yes, That is absolutely part of what this is about.
And most importantly, that's what it's about.
But it doesn't only point us forward
to Jesus as our champion.
See, listen, Romans 15,
four talks about everything happening to Israel as written
for our instruction both what to do and what not to do.
It was part of why it was recorded.
That means as we examine
how everyone in this narrative responded
to the giant problem they faced, that means we can learn
that God fights through those who trust him.
We can believe that. We can believe that God does fight
through those who trust him.
It doesn't mean we go fight like pick fights with the enemy
and we go try to find Satan so that we can pick a fight.
No, it just means we know how to stand firm.
When our enemy tries to challenge God
and tries to challenge his people, it means
that we don't trust the world's means for victory.
We trust God for victory.
It means that we are willing to be used if God wants
to use even us to do something like this.
It means God works and fights through those who trust him.
And listen in your life
and my life, it might not look as drastic
as cutting off the head of Goliath, But you can trust
that when you believe in God
and you believe in his power,
that he is winning battles in your life.
You can trust him, you can obey him,
and you can believe that he's going to do what he wants
to do and he's going to win battles.
He's working to shine His glory even brighter through those
who trust him, through those who obey him so
that all the world may know who God is.
You can trust it, you can believe it,
you can follow him in it.
But there's even deeper layer to all this as well.
And I think it's really subtle here in chapter 17,
but I think it's really important for us to understand
to even get to that level of belief
and trust in God,
each of us need to stop
and consider what story am I listening to?
What story am I listening to? Ask yourself that here.
Here's what I mean. You remember early in this narrative,
all we heard were the claims of the Philistines sixteens.
They were saying, Hey, this is a battle
between your army and our army.
And look at how big our champion is.
Look at how strong he is. Look at his military.
Might look at how weak you guys are compared to who he is.
Look at how powerful he is.
And how did Saul and his army respond?
They were dismayed, greatly afraid.
They were, listen, hear this.
They were listening to the story of the world.
They were listening to the story of the Philistines,
the story of the enemy, the story of their own flesh.
Instead of listening to the story
that God had told them, instead
of believing what God had already said,
remember he said he would deliver them.
Do you remember He said he was going
to win battles for them.
He said he was going to bless them.
They forgot that and they listened to
that story in front of them.
Listen, it reminds me of numbers 13.
Moses sent 12 spies into the promised land to scout it out,
to check it out, see how great it is so that they can know
how they're going to move forward.
They all saw when those 12 went into the land,
they all saw the same thing.
They saw giants, they saw fortified cities.
They saw everything in front of them
that they then had a choice whether they were going
to believe what they saw that was scary
or they were going to believe what God had said and done.
You remember, God had promised the land.
They had no doubt if they really believed
that God had promised it all was in front of them.
They also had seen God deliver them from Egypt,
split the sea wide open defeat enemies left
and right the whole time.
They had every reason to trust they could know
that God was going to deliver them and only two of them did.
Two of the 12 believed God.
Is that not the same thing that's happening here in Isaiah?
In in one Samuel 17, Saul
and Israel, they allowed the Philistine story
to shape their views of what was happening.
That it was about strength and power.
And military might instead of remembering who God is.
But David saw the same giant, heard the same
story, but instead of hiding
or bribing other people to try to take over,
he believed in God's glory more than anything else.
Listen, is that not a daily struggle for us as well?
Is that not the same thing we face?
How are we listening to the wrong stories?
How are we listening to falsehoods?
How are we not listening to truth?
'cause there are competing narratives all
around us every single day.
And you know what I'm talking about?
Things like, well, this is how you win at life.
This will satisfy you. You need to do this to be fulfilled.
You need to do this so you can win.
And all of those things, or even the narratives
that you hear that man you, you can never overcome, that
you're weak, God doesn't care about you,
or whatever other story you
or your flesh gets tossed, that enemy throws it in your mind
and you think about that.
Listen, how are you choosing instead to listen to the story
of God like two, the reality
of this God who has no competitors to his throne, the God
who cannot be defeated, the God
who has already overcome the world,
the God whose glory will shine to the ends of the earth.
This same God who fills you with his power, the same God
who has a good plan for your life when you trust him
and obey him, this God who works
through those who trust him.
This God who's not afraid of a puny little giant,
that is the true story we need to listen to over
and over and over again.
Listen, that's why we soak in His word
so that we can listen to his story
that defines everything else
and so we can trust him more no matter what we face.
That's also why we do the Lord's Supper.
Listen, we, we trust God's sovereign.
We did not plan like this for this sermon,
but it works to where
the Lord's supper pictures a
story of victory.
It shows us that Jesus life, death,
and resurrection is enough
to bring the victory for you and for me.
And man, we forget that. We doubt it.
I was bad this week, probably gone too far.
Whatever it is, right? We've done these things
and we doubt this story is what we need to be listening to.